oui
[Musique]
professeur carlo revelli c'est
formidable de vous avoir avec nous
bienvenue dans notre émission merci de
m'avoir invité
je vais commencer par une question très
direct
vous dites qu'il n'ya pas de temps sens
strict du terme
corrigez moi si je me trompe et que le
temps n'existe que dans les yeux de
celui qui regarde et dépend de la
perception de leur droit où se trouve le
spectateur et de ce qu'ils regardent
mais nous ressentons et éprouvons
l'écoulement du temps ou plutôt nous
avons le sentiment que les choses se
succèdent
le voilà par exemple je prends un
téléphone et puis je le pose il était
dans ma main maintenant il n'y est plus
n'est ce pas le temps yes date oui c'est
bien le temps pour nous bien sûr le
temps existe nous nous levons le matin
nous nous couchons le soir le temps
passe nous vieillissons c'est la réalité
quand je dis qu'il n'ya pas de temps ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
temps dans la nature même au niveau
fondamental
je vais vous donner un exemple si vous
le permettez il faille série
si je dis que le soleil ne bouge pas
d'un stand et immobile ne se déplace pas
cela ne signifie pas qu'il n'ya pas de
coucher du soleil on voit toujours le
soleil se lever et se coucher à mais on
comprend que ce n'est pas vraiment le
soleil qui bouge c'est toute une
histoire complexe entre nous et le
soleil car nous sommes assis sur un gros
rocher en rotation donc de notre point
de vue le soleil se déplace le mouvement
du soleil que nous voyons est réelle
mais ce n'est pas propre au soleil même
c'est pareil pour le temps le temps est
un phénomène plus complexe qu'on ne
l'imaginent c'est ce que la physique a
montré le temps est différent de ce
qu'on en pense le temps en tel qu'il
apparaît dans notre vie quotidienne
n'existe pas dans la nature la nature
est plus complexe
un exemple à un supposons que vous ayez
une horloge ou une montre qui donne
l'heure
nous savons tous que la propriété des
horloges et de mesurer le temps donc
c'est le même temps pour tout
si je les regarde je vois qu'elle donne
la même heure je regarde à nouveau
c'est toujours pareil mais en fait si
nous le mesurons plus précisément ce
n'est pas tout à fait vrai si on prend
deux bons mécanismes pas celui-là a
scellé remonte de mon grand-père son
mécanisme n'est pas particulièrement bon
mais si nous prenons un bon mécanisme
que nous le plaçons un peu plus haut
attendons un peu et regardons nous
verrons que cette montre ne donne pas la
même heure parce que plus de temps s'est
écroulé en haut qu'en bas et cela peut
être mesuré aujourd'hui dans un
laboratoire
le temps est donc différent de ce que
l'on croit le temps créée par notre
imagination habituel est illusoire
c'est une approximation c'est comme pour
le soleil d'accord on reviendra cette
expérience plus tard mais avant de
plonger dans les aspects scientifiques
de votre conception du temps je voudrais
juste rendre ce dernier plus clair pour
nous simples humains parce que pour moi
la preuve la plus évidente de
l'existence du temps et le
vieillissement de nos corps le fait que
nous finissons tous par mourir je veux
dire nous faisons partie de la nature
n'est ce pas nous faisons également
partie d'un plus grand ensemble je crois
que je fais partie de quelque chose de
plus grand qui fait lui-même partie de
moi donc contesté vous que le temps pris
dans ce sens là existent aussi pour moi
même si je fais partie de l'immense
nature dont vous parliez
le temps est très réel pour moi parce
que non je ne nie pas je pense que vous
l'avez formulée très correctement le
temps existe pour nous nous vieillissons
plus que ça nous nous souvenons du passé
et nous pensons à l'avenir et nous
savons que nous sommes mortels donc nous
avons tête cette conception de la vie
passé présent futur
tout cela est réel
mais ça ne concerne que nous-mêmes ce
n'est pas comme ça qu'une étoile vie
c'est une étoile ne se souvient pas du
passé et ne pensent pas l'avenir weeks
nous faisons partie de la nature et nous
percevons les choses qui dépendent de
nos propriétés naturelles et non de
propriété universel mais canada un autre
exemple voici la direction vers le haut
et voilà la direction vers le bas
tout est faux non bien sûr c'est correct
je veux dire il y à un haut et un bas
les choses tombent mais je me trouve au
canada et vous en géorgie si je pointe
vers le haut de mon côté et si vous
pointer vers le haut du vôtre ce sont
des directions différentes
alors lequel est le vrai haut vous
comprenez ça semble être la même chose
mais en réalité nous pointons dans des
directions différentes
parce que la terre est ronde et donc
nous pointons dans des directions
différentes
alors lequel est le vrai haut eh bien
cela n'existe pas il ya un os pour moi
est un os pour vous et si votre frère
était astronaute et qu'il flottait dans
l'espace le haut ne veut rien dire pour
lui parce que pour lui toutes les
directions seraient les mêmes donc il
n'ya pas de haut dans l'univers et
l'univers n'a pas d'orientation vers le
bas at des âmes a promis or il ya un os
pour moi et pour vous également il y un
os qui est une autre direction
il en va de même pour le temps il n'y a
pas de temps général dans l'univers
l'univers n'a pas de temps mais nous
créatures qui évoluons dans un
environnement où il ya de la chaleur où
il y a une longue histoire
nous sommes soumis à des phénomènes
locaux et notamment notre propre temps
et en regardant attentivement on peut
voir ces différences voir comment le
temps s'écoule à une autre attitude
alors pourquoi le temps s'il n'existe
pas au niveau microscopique at il une
direction
pourquoi ne s'écoule t-il jamais dans
l'autre sens excellente question
il a été surprenant de découvrir à
mesure que la physique évolué soler et
que le temps était différent de notre
conception habituel
sur des sujets cède on a compris que le
temps pouvait s'écouler plus vite ou
ralentir il y a environ 100 ans
einstein a été le premier à découvrir
cela il est parvenu à cette idée de
manière théorique il a essayé en quelque
sorte d'associer diverses choses que
nous savions sur la nature mais on est
maintenant capable de le mesurer en
laboratoire ce n'est plus seulement une
idée d'einstein
c'est quelque chose de réel et mesurable
mais plutôt encore une autre grande
découverte a été que les lois de la
physique ne distingue pas le passé du
futur et c'est très étrange parce que
pour nous le passé est complètement
différent de l'avenir n'est ce pas le
passé et fixe on ne peut pas le changer
je suis né tel jour et je ne peux rien y
changer
il ya eu la révolution russe au début du
siècle dernier et c'est ainsi et
l'avenir semble ouvert on a l'impression
que ce sont des histoires complètement
séparés mais la physique ne distingue
pas le passé du futur
il ya eu beaucoup de discussions sur ce
que cela signifie
il s'est avéré que la différence entre
le passé et l'avenir ne se manifeste que
lorsque nous passons sur les détails
c'est ce que nous faisons tout le temps
parce que nous ne voyons pas les atomes
bouger même à toutes les choses se
déplace dans une direction
c'est ce que les physiciens appellent la
croissance de l'entropie comme ça que ça
s'appelle la différence entre le passé
et le futur
on utilise ce mot en physique c'est
difficile à concevoir parce que nous
pensons terme de passer et d'avenir
mais encore une fois c'est parce que
nous sommes de très grands objets par
rapport aux atomes et molécules
avez vous vu le film de christopher
nolan
je veux dire ce qui s'y passe est-ce que
c'est théoriquement possible non nolan a
pris cette idée le concept d'entropie et
s
oui il a adopté cette idée qui est
fondamentalement correcte pourrait être
possible de voyager dans le passé ou
d'aller dans le futur en jouant sur
l'entropie et en changeant la
disposition des molécules
en principe c'est la réalité quand ce
remake est mauvais mais le film qu'il a
fait est absurde car nous ne pouvons pas
ranger les molécules à notre guise c'est
un produit hollywoodien c'est plutôt de
l'ordre de la fantasy et je les trouvais
un peu confus et compliqué la beauté du
problème du temps ce qui nous fascine
tous à propos du temps et sacs et des
autres c'est qu'il y à toute cette
complexité c'est qu'il y ait un aspect
du temps présent dans la mécanique des
choses dans la thermodynamique des
choses beaucoup beaucoup d'atomes bouge
dans votre cerveau on le constate même
en psychologie dirais-je
vous avez commencé en dix ans et c'est
très bien selon moi oui que le temps
chez nous se manifester dans le
vieillissement et vous savez le temps
pour nous c'est aussi quelque chose qui
emporte tout ce que nous avons n'est ce
pas nous savons que nous allons perdre
tout ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui nous
allons mourir tous les gens que nous
aimons disparaîtront et nous ne vivrons
pas éternellement
cela crée de l'anxiété cependant le
temps nous apporte aussi des choses nous
avons un lien très émotionnel avec le
temps notre cerveau est organisée de
telle manière que nous tendons à saisir
le futur et c'est ainsi que nous avons
peur de perdre quelque chose du passé
c'est ça que nous entendons par là dans
une large mesure quand nous parlons de
temps en tant que physicien je fais de
la science mais un physicien fait fausse
route s'il dit ok je ne veux pas penser
à la psychologie
j'explore uniquement le mouvement des
choses et on ne comprend plus ce qu'est
le temps pour nous le temps pour nous en
grande partie c'est cet aspect
émotionnel du temps nous allons faire
une pause à notre retour nous
reprendrons notre entretien avec le
professeur carlo revelli physicien
théoricien
auteur à succès nous essaierons de
comprendre si le temps existe ou non
rester avec nous
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour pour reprendre
notre discussion avec le professeur
carlo revelli sur la notion de temps est
ce une illusion ou une réalité si le
temps est plutôt une conception humaine
puisque l'émotion est quelque chose de
très humain ou même une illusion on
encense comment les physiciens comme
vous-même peuvent-ils l'utiliser pour
savoir ce qui s'est passé lors du big
bang
je ne sais pas cela m'a toujours
passionné de lire comment une telle ou
une telle chose était apparu deux ou
trois nano seconde après le big bang
tout cela n'est qu'une illusion je
trouve cela fascinant moi aussi c'est
une grande partie de mon travail
essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est
produit juste après le big bang
cela fait partie de mon travail
quotidien de contribuer à l'étude de ce
qui se passe quand nous étudions le big
bang
nous partons du principe qu'il a eu lieu
il ya très longtemps qu'est-ce que cela
signifie
le big bang a eu lieu il ya 13 14
milliards d'années et flûte et cordes si
on prend toutes les horloges et qu'on
remonte dans le temps elles sont
différentes mais en moyenne si on
remonte le temps de 14 milliards
d'années c'est le big bang
mveng est confuse mais il ya une
confusion à cause du big bang il faisait
si chaud et tout était si comprimés que
cela a créé une situation quantique et
c'est une physique très différente de la
science à laquelle nous sommes habitués
nous sommes si profondément plongés dans
le régime de gravité quantique quand
même la notion de temps des physiciens
n'est plus bonne il faut la modifier un
peu mais nous n'avons pas compris ce
qu'il s'est exactement passé au moment
du big bang peut-être que le temps
n'existait pas du tout et que c'est
alors que le temps a commencé les
chercheurs essaient de formuler des
équations expliquant ce qui se passe
date
qu'allah soit la peine de les comparer
aux observations du ciel pour élaborer
une bonne conception
comme vous l'avait déjà évoqué le
problème avec la notion habituel de
temps des youyous soit la notion
physique
celle de l'équation de maxwell de
l'équation de newton celle qu'on
étudiait à l'école
vous savez ce tarif physx une pendule
qui se déplace dans le temps même cette
notion là n'est plus correct pour moi
c'est la beauté de la physique
elle nous oblige à repenser nos notions
de base parfois d'une manière tout à
fait clair que nous avons pleinement
comprise c'est copernic qui nous dit que
nous ne sommes pas immobile que nous
bougeons parfois on se retrouve à la
frontière entre le connu et l'inconnu à
la limite de nos connaissances lorsque
même les notions que nous utilisons tout
le temps ne sont plus claires donc tout
n'est pas clair à propos du temps ce qui
s'est exactement passé au moment du big
bang et toujours sujet à débat nous
avons dit précédemment que le temps ne
s'écoule est jamais à l'envers il peut
seulement avancé donc si le temps est
une flèche qui va vers l'avant
cela signifie t'il qu'en réalité nous
restons statique parce que le temps
n'existe pas vraiment ou avançons nous
avec lui non je ne crois pas que nous
restions statique ce n'est pas aussi
simple
quand je dis ou quand les physiciens
disent parfois que le temps n'existe pas
les gens imaginent que l'univers n'est
qu'un bloc et que rien ne s'y passe mais
c'est une image trompeuse parce que si
rien ne se passe ce que vous imaginez
c'est qu'il y a par exemple un rocher
que le temps passe et que le rocher ne
change pas sort donc en affirmant que
rien ne se passe
on sous-entend le temps passe mais rien
ne change
mais en réalité c'est le contraire
l'univers est en train de changer
voilà ce qui se passe l'univers a lieu
il y a beaucoup de choses qui
surviennent dans l'univers figurez vous
qu'il y ait beaucoup beaucoup
d'événements mais ils ne sont pas rangés
aux mises en ordre dans le temps commun
ils sont en quelque sorte désordonnée
[Musique]
c'est notre façon d'organiser les choses
par la mémoire et par l'anticipation qui
fait que nous voyons les événements
l'univers comme une unique séquence de
choses se déroulent en ce qui est une
erreur pas de prison
dailynord vous comprenez quand je dis
que le soleil ne bouge pas oui nous
voyons le soleil se lever et se coucher
tous les jours on voit ce mouvement puis
nous allons à l'école et notre
professeur ou notre père notre mère nous
dit tu sais c'est une illusion
le soleil ne bouge pas mais cela ne
signifie pas que le soleil s'arrête
il est bloqué dans le ciel et ne va plus
bouger pour nous le soleil continue de
tourner ce n'est tout simplement pas le
soleil même qui se déplacent c'est plus
complexe
je voudrais évoquer la musique oui c'est
quelque chose qui n'existe vraiment que
lorsqu'elles se déroulent dans le temps
mais ce pas quand les instruments jouent
ensemble
il y à un rythme ou une impulsion qui
donnent vie au temps et nous ne le
ressentons que lorsque la musique évolue
dans le temps
la note qui ne changent pas devient un
bourdonnement qui n'a pas de sens comme
disons un frigo qui vibre donc si au
niveau de la physique élémentaire
le temps n'a pas d'importance où
n'existe pas pourquoi s'il à leurs
importants à un niveau non alimentaire
au niveau de la musique par exemple
cela veut dire que la musique créée
l'automne excellente question
dans l'élaboration du concept de temps
la musique a joué un grand rôle
supposons que vous entendiez des
musiques une chanson à un moment donné à
ce moment précis vous entendez une seule
note mais pas toute la chanson et
l'instant d'après vous entendez une
autre note mais vous n'entendez jamais
la chanson vous ne percevez qu'une seule
note à la fois à chaque instant vous
entendez une seule note alors pourquoi
vous percevez des sons comme une chanson
si elle n'existe pas telle quelle dans
la nature nietzsche ou à chaque instant
il n'y a qu'une note à la fois à des
cités comme ça avant la découverte du
principe d' harmonie la musique était
majoritairement mélodique
ok alors quelle est la réponse diane
seul si vous réfléchissez un instant
elle est évidente et lorsque vous
entendez une note plus votre cerveau se
souvient des notes précédentes
wright il suffit de rejouer dans la tête
votre mélodies préférées pour le
comprendre il est membre
vous entendez un son et en même temps
vous vous souvenez du précédent depuis
deux soirs
so you think you cry la mélodie n'existe
que dans votre mémoire
au-delà de votre cerveau il n'y a qu'une
seule note à la fois une des choses et
cela montre qu'une grande partie de
notre sentiment
aw et de notre perception de la
temporalité est lié à notre mémoire
permettez moi d'expliquer les choses
ainsi et une pierre ne peut pas entendre
de musique country music
mais car elle n'a pas de mémoire
toujours entendre de la musique vous
avez besoin de mémoire et la mémoire
nécessite un cerveau ou plutôt un
ordinateur pas forcément un cerveau
parce que nous sommes des êtres
spirituels différent du reste de la
nature j'estime que nous sommes des
éléments de la nature comme tout le
reste mais que nous sommes des éléments
très particulier avec beaucoup de
connexions neuronales
c'est cette particularité qui permet à
la musique d'exister dans un sens très
concret music xxl la musique ne peut
exister que grâce à notre cerveau qui se
souvient et ce n'est pas seulement cela
tout le monde sait que lorsque vous
entendez un extrait d'une mélodie votre
cerveau anticipe ce qui viendra ensuite
next et cela se transforme en musique la
musique et tout un jeu la musique joue
et partiellement vous obtenez ce à quoi
vous vous attendez la note suivante vous
la reconnaissez et ce mécanisme vous
rend heureux
en partie seulement c'est une surprise
parce qu'il ya des éléments inconnus
c'est un jeu de surprises et de
satisfaction qui engendre la musique
donc encore une fois la musique née dans
notre cerveau cela ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas d' onde sonore c'est
tout à fait vrai elle existe mais ce que
nous appellerons la musique est produit
par notre cerveau absolument passionnant
merci
je voudrais revenir à l'expérience de la
montre d'accord mais des rangs cela me
dépasse
parce que je vois le temps comme quelque
chose d'universel une minute et la même
essien géorgiques quelque part à new
delhi 9 heures dans un avion pour new
york sont partout les mêmes ici sur
terre
cilly à différentes vitesses autant
pourquoi on ne le ressent pas je veux
dire jusqu'où dois-je montée pour
ressentir une différence et puis notre
perception subjective
vous parlez de mémoire là mais j'ai
l'impression que la perception est aussi
quelque chose tout une scène à
distinguer le temps donc ma perception
subjective du temps me permettrait-elle
de le ressentir si je me trouve à une
altitude suffisante
oui permettez moi pour répondre à ces
deux questions je commencerai par la
deuxième votre perception subjective
saisir et elle cela oui absolument
il ya des films interstellar par exemple
dans lesquels le héros s'approche
d'objets très lourd et donc le temps
ralentit considérablement pour lui quand
il revient sur terre pour lui quelques
jours seulement ont passé alors qu'ici
ce sont des années à la fin du film
quand il revient sur terre ou à sa fille
est devenue une vieille dame
le personnage principal est resté un
homme d'âge moyen alors que sa fille est
déjà une vieille dame
la perception subjective du temps a donc
été complètement différente pour eux
nous en sommes certains c'est de la
physique des solides on comprend ça et
maintenant vous vous demandez pourquoi
ne percevons nous pas cela comme vous le
disiez une minute pour vous c'est aussi
une minute pour moi et bien la raison en
est que tant que nous restons sur terre
que ce soit en géorgie au canada à new
delhi
dès que nous vivions dans la montagne
sur le mont everest qui est le plus haut
sommet du monde
ces différences sont très faibles
extrêmement faible pendant mes cours de
physique je demande parfois à mes
étudiants de faire un exercice qui
consiste à calculer la différence de
temps par exemple votre frère vit dans
les montagnes dans un village situé plus
haut que vous ne pouvez l'imaginer bilan
des cent cinquante ans après quelle sera
la différence de temps il l'a calculé il
s'avère que cette différence n'est
qu'une fraction de seconde
c'est à dire qu'elle est trop petit pour
que nous la ressentons ici si vous avez
les instruments vous pouvez la mesurer
et nous la mesure on est ce qui est
impressionnant c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous
pouvons mesurer une telle différence non
seulement dans la montagne mais aussi
pour des emplacements qui sont 20 cm
plus haut ou 20 cm plus bas nous pouvons
voir qu'une horloge va plus vite et
l'autre plus lentement
le gps que nous utilisons en voiture ce
système qui nous localise fonctionne
avec des satellites
au début ces satellites ont été mis en
orbite par les américains dans les
années 1970 puis les russes les chinois
et les indiens ont fait de même
nous avons beaucoup de systèmes de ce
type aujourd'hui lorsque les américains
ont mis les premiers satellites en
orbite
les physiciens ont dit aux ingénieurs
attention parce que là haut
le temps va plus vite et comme il y à
une horloge sur le satellite
je vais vous raconter comment ça
fonctionne il ya des horloges sur le
satellite
ce dernier envoie un signal horaire sur
terre puis votre petit appareil
l'utilisent pour vous localiser
comme je voulais déjà dit les
scientifiques ont dit attention le temps
là où va plus vite
ghost writer les ingénieurs ont adapté
le système mais ils étaient entre les
mains des militaires est un général de
l'armée américaine a dit allez c'est
ridicule
le temps va plus vite je n'y crois pas
donc au début sur les premiers
satellites les expérimentaux août il
avait des récepteurs qui synchronise l
horloge interne et il pouvait en tenir
compte ou pas mais ça ne marche pas si
vous n'en tenez pas compte donc
technologiquement lorsque vous conduisez
votre voiture et que le gps qui vous
dans quelle direction aller 6 le système
fonctionne de telle manière qu'il doit
tenir compte du fait que le temps passe
plus vite la hausse face à cela fait
partie de notre technologie aujourd'hui
c'est fascinant
j'aimerais pouvoir parler encore des
heures pour discuter de la notion de
temps c'était vraiment intéressant
d'aborder le problème de perception du
temps afin de savoir s'il s'agit d'une
illusion ou si ça existe vraiment merci
beaucoup pour ce merveilleux entretien
je vous souhaite bonne chance et espère
qu'on se reverra bientôt
merci je l'espère aussi et merci pour
vos questions qui étaient très
pertinentes
le sujet est fascinant et j'espère
pouvoir vous parler à nouveau théo galy
oui je vous remercie prenez soin de vous
[Musique]